talking about the fering complexity of
the task of direct access for
conjuncting queries with agregation I'll
explain what all of that means um so
this is ongoing work so I'm telling you
in advance that there's a lot we still
don't know but I'll tell you about what
we do know this is Joint work with Idan
elar and with Benny keld and um also
Idan is going to talk about this in just
a few months
in so um before anything else let's
start with a motivating example okay so
um let's say we have some sort of online
platform uh and we have uh people who
contribute to create some resources uh
and then we have another table that
tells us uh how many views each resource
received uh in a
day and let's say we want to get a sense
of to how many views a contributor
contribute okay
um so for for to get a sense of when we
look at a specific person any any person
uh what's the impact what's the the
number of views that he contributed to
in some way okay um so how would we go
about doing this with the with the
information we have here um well uh we
probably want to create the sort of
table of the sum of views per
contributor and how we do we would do
that um we can have this um I I have
this query as the sort of conjunctive
query like notation with Aggregates um
so we want to join the tables and then
we want to Su over the views and then
the
contributors so to compute this um what
we can do is First We join the two
relations then we Group by the
contributor and um then we sum uh in
each uh the views in each group and
afterwards we probably want to sort by
the
views
Okay so so let's say we have a lot of
contributors we have a huge table what
do we do with this table now right we're
not going to look at over all of the
rows so maybe we want to know what's the
median uh number of views maybe we want
more than that a box plot so in addition
to the Min to the median we want the
minimum the maximum the other quartiles
or maybe we want some sort of histogram
so we have a the bins of the number of
views we want to know how many
contributors fall within each
question question uh each view is
associated with only one contributor
we're not sharing the weight of the
views amongst multiple
contributors um if I understand your
question correctly um you mean like if
two people contribute to one view I'm
going to count the view for both people
like an entire view for both people
right that's yes so that's what I do I I
I just want to know in how many views
you impacted in some way I don't want to
quantify your exact it's not a flow kind
of thing it's a yeah um for this I think
uh Benny worked on on this type of a
question of and maybe he's going to
mention this in his talk on Friday I
don't
know
okay um right so what's the complexity
of what we just described how long would
it take us to do all of this
stuff well um the expensive component
here is actually the join right for
joining two relations um it's going to
be a quadratic time algorithm the output
of the joint can be quadratic and then
everything else is more or less linear
in the result of the
joint but if you notice the the the
amount of like actual information we
need for these things it's it's not a
lot of like pieces of information so
what we want to know is whether we can
compute these things without actually
materializing the entire join result but
sort of get these things immediately
directly and save a a lot of
time and well yes we can for this query
and also for queries that are more
complicated but not always very
efficiently and this is what I'm trying
to explain uh in this talk so more
specifically the the the query answering
task we would be considering is a ranked
direct access so what this means is that
we want to uh simulate a sorted array
that contains the answers um so um we
would have some sort of data structure
that receives an index and return the
answer in this index um and the the
ranking is specified by the user along
with the
query so what this means is that if we
have this sort of standard approach for
query answering that we uh if we have an
algorithm we specify a database we get
the query answers here our approach is
different the algorithm doesn't
immediately produce the query answers it
produces this sort of data structure you
can call it a factorized database if you
want and um then you can ask this sort
of access calls of this data structure
and get the the the answers in these
Ines okay is that
clear now why do I think that this task
is so
interesting um because it can be used to
solve many other tasks um that are quite
common so first of all um we can use
ranked access for quantile computation
and for computing histograms uh which is
what I mentioned uh before
second of all um we can use ranked
access to get pagination so basically
imagine you have a lot of answers you
want to show the first page of the the
best answers and then you want to the
user to be able to click to go to the
other answers this is like um offset and
limit
basically um and if you have ranked
access you can do it more efficiently
that what's typically done without
actually producing all of the answers
first if you want a specific page
um and this is equivalent to ranked
access actually in a way because if your
pages are of size one if you're allowed
to choose the Del be on of size one then
this page nation is exactly rank
Texas what else we can do well we can do
ranked
enumeration um which is what Nikos was
talking about in the previous talk if
you just access the says one after the
other one two three four and
so and then there are also things can do
that are um regardless of the specific
ranking you use even if you don't uh
force a specific ranking on the simulat
right um so first of all you can do
counting um if you just binary search to
see when you get out of
bound and you can also use direct access
uh to get a uniformly random ordered
enumeration um which is sampling without
repetitions um this citation here in
case you want to see how this
transitions
done uh and of course if you have
enumeration then it's just gives you a
way of producing all of the query
answers if this is what she
wants okay question so
far good so um the question um that
we're going to be to be asking well
ideally what we would want to know is uh
given a query in an order what's the
best algorithm the best complexity we
can do to solve this query in terms of
fine grain
complexity
um and as an intermediate question we
would like to ask which queries we can
solve with the ideal time guarantees um
so quasy linear preprocessing so linear
preprocessing in constant time per
answer would be the ideal and let's
allow some logarithmic factors to to be
able to actually do
stuff um and the focus in this talk
would be for conjunctive queries with
segregation and lexicographic
orders okay so this was the
motivation and uh let's now tell you
about a little bit what we know about
this so first let's mention what happens
for conjunctive queries without
Aggregates I'll just briefly mention
what we know without going into the
details um so when we have a conjunctive
query without Aggregates we and we have
specific lexicographic order we want to
achieve so we have an ordering of the
fre variables of the query we can do
that
efficiently uh exactly in the cases
where so first of all the query has to
be a cyclic the same definition of a
cyclic that Nikos was mentioning in Fon
um so this is what we need even just to
to enumerate the answers of joint
queries it has to be free conic which
means that um so definition of a cly is
having a joint Tre of ronic query on top
of being a cyclic it needs to also
remain a cyclic when you add another
hyperedge that contains exactly the free
variables of the
query um so this means that the
projections behave nicely and then we
have this extra condition that tells us
uh that the lexicographic order we want
to achieve uh is something we can
achieve um so this is equivalent to
saying that the lexicographic order is
the reverse of an elimination order for
those of you who know what it is but if
you don't there is like actually a
condition that's quite easy to to
understand or verify that tells us what
are the interesting orders um so the the
good orders are the ones that don't have
a disruptive Trio so disruptive Trio is
three variables such that the last one
in the order we want to achieve uh
shares atoms with the previous two but
the previous two are not neighbors they
don't appear together on an
atom so here are examples um and in my
my notation here in the slide the order
where I put the variables in the head
matters okay so here I specify
conjunctive query and I also specify the
lexicographic order that I want to
achieve so these are both the same query
but with different lexicographic orders
uh you can see that the first one has a
disruptive Trio so it doesn't have
efficient direct access but the second
one
doesn't
um so um if this uh holds we have an
efficient algorithm if this doesn't hold
we have a hardness proof this hardness
proof like all hardness proof in in the
ram model requires some assumptions but
I W don't want to spend too much time on
these
assumptions um it's very similar to
assumptions that were used before for
for similar PRS and also if you heard me
talk before about self joints and how
much they cause problems in the
complexity analysis of enumeration it's
not a problem here actually we can show
that the complexity remains pretty much
the same logarithmic factors if you even
if you have self
Choice okay
so um this was without aggregation now
what happens when we want conjunctive
queries with
aggregation so our idea is surprise
surprise use Sam
Rings um so we we translate the
aggregations to saring and you can see
here an example ex if this is uh what we
want to solve
um these are the answers you're
expecting to get this is the array
you're trying to
simulate and the way we would solve it
is uh basically we want to sum over W so
um we add annotations to the to our tles
and then uh on the table r that contains
W the annotations would be the value of
w and then we use a summering um where
um the basically sum up these these W
values so the answers to this um
um to this query over this annotated
database would be what we're trying to
get
basically so now we're using annotations
but how do we solve the query with the
annotations um so first all we need to
handle the
projections um so in this case we don't
want the W value so we need to get rid
of it um so we project in R and then uh
we sum over the
annotations and then once we eliminate
and and in general whenever we have
queries that are cyclic and free conic
we can do that
efficiently and then once we uh we we
have a full conjunctive query with
annotations we use the direct access
algorithm that was known for conjunctive
query
this algorithm tells us we we just
ignore the annotations for for now this
algorithm tells us the assignment for x
and y and this tells us which choules we
need to take from each relation so now
we look back at the annotations we
multiply them and we get the answer we
wanted to
get so actually using these uh semi
rings and this this idea of annotating
the topples we could support this quite
elegantly and and efficiently
so this was uh one example in general we
have a dichotomy that tells us that
whenever we have this query with a
lexographic order uh where we have an we
want to get an annotation at the end of
the lexographic order so the The
annotation doesn't affect the ordering
in the simulated array then the
tractable cases are exactly the same
tractable cases we had it doesn't cost
us anything to add this
AG
right so I guess we all know in general
what comput commutative sings are at
this point uh we need them to be we need
the operations to be able to to to be
able to be calculated efficiently in up
to logarithmic time for our analysis
here uh and we have of course this
approach we saw before where we uh
annotate toppos with s element when we
use topples jointly we multiply the
elements when we use them we have a
choice then we use the
addition so what kind of things what
kind of aggregate can we solve in
General on top of this specific example
I showed you here uh with this
annotations so uh we can very easily
support uh sum and count using the
summering where summation is summation
multiplication is
multiplication uh and we can easily
support mean and Max using the tropical
C now what happens if we want to solve
other common aggregate functions what
are other common aggregate functions so
for example average um we can also do
that efficiently by just accessing an
answer and Computing it sum and then
accessing the same answer and Computing
its count just the same way we did
before as black boxes and dividing the
two so we get the average yeah
youan uh I mean I mean that the
operations can be done in up to
logarithmic
time um right so this was average and
then uh anyone wants to guess what the
other aggregate that I want to
support
sorry median ah I do but as Nico said
like we don't even know how to do it for
more simple things but if I'm thinking
of things that people uh usually use
like in SQL and stuff well there's count
distinct um so cond distinct
um there's no saring transl translation
so we can't use the same approach we had
so far uh and then the question oh no
spoiler and then the question is um do
do we just have do we just need a
different approach to to solve this and
get the same guarantees or is it really
harder than the other Aggregates and
then we found out that it really is
harder than the other Aggregates and you
can see it on this uh example here uh if
you replace cond distinct with any
aggregate any other aggregate we
mentioned this is easy because it's a
cyclic and free conics and with no
disruptive tra so according to what we
said before but with C distinct we have
evidence we have a proof that shows that
it is uh actually
hard but but our proof uh uses the fact
that Z the values the variable Z needs
to be able to have a very large domain
to get assigned a lot of uh possibly a
lot of values can be assigned there and
if you happen to know that uh the the
number of possible assignments to Z is
small it has a log size domain then
actually you can do count distinct
efficiently by just using the set sing
and Computing the set of all values that
Z can get and then at the end you just
take the size of the
set okay so this to us what happens when
the aggregation doesn't affect the
order now what happens in the more
complicated case when we want the
agation to be able to affect the lexical
graphic
order uh and I'm going to just give you
a sense of the type of thing we find out
using
examples so the first example is like
what we saw before uh The annotation is
last in the lexicographic order and The
annotation is actually a function of the
X and y values which means that it
doesn't affect the order at all and we
saw that this is tractable for this
quer it's a cylic and free conic and
with no
disruptive now what happens if we want
The annotation to be first in the
order well it turns out that this query
is hard we have a proof uh that this
quer is hard assuming the well-known
conjecture through which is really bad
news because this is quite a simple
query right we would want to support
that
efficiently okay what can we still do
let's say The annotation is in the
middle is it still hard or is it easy
what happens now well uh it turns out
that it's easy um we have a a result
that tells us that in general whenever
an order is can be solved efficiently
when The annotation is at the end we're
allowed to push The annotation one
position backwards so we're allowed to
have one variable iable after The
annotation U or a set of variables that
behave like one variable in a
way so this is
easy and uh at this point we say
okay so here on the slide we have one
thing that's hard and quite simple which
is a shame we would still like to be
able to do things like this what happens
when we have the sort of aggregate
queries that we would naturally
translate to this hard query Q2 so Q4
here using the same kind of translation
to annotations I showed you before we
would have we would want to solve Q2 for
it if Q2 is hard does it necessarily
mean that Q4 is hard or do we lose some
efficiency in this sort of translation
to
aggregations
um now you can notice here that in this
translation uh only the relation R gets
interesting annotations uh since s
doesn't contain W here it always
contains one and in our hardness proof
using threeome in our construction we
were we had to put in s like different
interesting annotations so this doesn't
necessarily it's not necessarily as hard
as before and actually it's
easy so the way we can solve it for this
query we can just uh imagine here we
have another variable introduce another
variable this would be another column in
our table and then we get the query here
that's a sign and Freon and with no
disrup so this query can be soled
efficiently and our example is easy we
were able to show that it's easy by
going through these annotations and then
getting rid of the annotations but
because the annotations are local they
only appear in one relation we use this
fact um now there's some just one more
thing I would like to mention here um is
that that here in this uh new
R this column that we introduce we have
a functional dependency so for each
value of x we will have one value of Zed
and this is something we can actually
use to get more tractable cases for
direct access so in this particular case
we didn't need it because the query is
already of a good structure but in
general we know that functional
dependencies can help us get more
tractable cases and also when we use it
with local annotations here in this uh
in this context functional dependencies
sometimes
help okay so when we have local
annotations um we have a full
characterization in some cases to know
when these local annotations can be Sol
efficiently and in the other cases they
cannot but maybe since I don't have a
lot of times I won't um spend too much
time exp
this uh right what does hard mean again
do you have a lower bound or yeah hard
hard means a lower bound it means that I
have a a conditional lower bound the
proof that sells that I cannot do direct
access with quasi linear time to build
the structure and then logarithmic time
per
AIS uh last examp I think it's the last
example I wanted to show you um so here
Q4 is easy
um Q5 is another query that if we
translate translate to our annotations
we would get Q2
again but in this case um since it's
something that uh in this case um we
don't get the annotations that the
annotations are
local um and so the question is again
does it mean that Q5 is hard just like
Q2 or can we somehow solve it in a
different way
and actually we show that we can solve
it in a different way we have an
algorithm uh but this is quite ad hoc um
so I don't know how much it exes sense
but this sort of tells us that this
annotations approach lead us very far
very elegantly to be able to support a
lot of things but this sort of evidence
that maybe it doesn't cover all of the
all of the efficiency that we can
get Okay so to
conclude um I spent quite time trying to
uh convince you why I think that rank
direct access is really cool problem
because it can solve um uh it can help
you find box plots and histograms and
and Imagination and a lot of other
tasks um then we saw the dichotomy that
we have for conjunctive queries without
aggregation and then we use this
dichotomy to introduce um a similar
dichotomy when we also have aggregation
but the aggregation doesn't affect the
order um then we saw that when we want
the aggregation to affect the order we
we uh hit interact ability quite fast
interact ability is a big word right I
just mean no quasi linear pre-processing
and logarithmic access time so we hit
that uh very quickly uh but then we can
still get some more tractable cases by
looking at local annotations and
sometimes in other
ways uh okay uh future work so first of
all as I said this is ongoing and there
are open cases and things we don't know
how to
classify regarding self joints so sub
joints is when you use uh the same
relation in different
atoms um so for the dichotomy without
aggregation and when the aggregation
doesn't affect the order this actually
holds just the same if you have self
joints or don't have self joints we have
a proove for that uh but when
aggregations affect the order then self
joints actually make things complicated
and all of our results are without self
joint point so it would be interesting
to to look at that and see what happens
there uh and in this uh talk and in this
work so far we only looked at what
whether we can do things with only quasi
linear preprocessing uh what happens to
the cases where we can't do that well
we'll be willing to pay a bit more
because we don't have another choice but
how much more do we need to pay um this
is um a question um that we still need
to ask if our question are only join
queries uh and so without projections
and without
aggregations um then we know exactly
what happens for lexicographic orders if
we want to achieve logarithmic access
time we know exactly what's the
pre-processing time we need and we have
a conditional or bound that tells us
that we can't do it with last but
already if we introduce
projections we don't know uh we know
that there are things that are more
efficient than the trivial thing you
would try to do with like using a
decomposition
and of course there is um we can make it
more complicated in many ways more
complicated ERS more complicated queries
maybe try to support updates over the
structure and so
on uh and this is all I prepared for you
thank
[Applause]
you
question
what in case of count distinct what
happens if youo if you allow
approximation well I don't know that's
the correct
answer there are sketching structures
for such things right yeah but requ
randomiz
yeah I'm a bit unclear why do you say
log time and not log space do do you
mean log time over numbers that
presented
in l
space right so um we're using well I
wasn't very specific about the model and
computation of everything so we're using
the ram model where um the the words or
registers are of logarithmic size and
typically we assume that the operations
take um constant time so summation and
application over these registered would
take constant time um but actually for
our results to hold it would also be
okay if the operations take logarithmic
time in the size of your database and um
we we use it for what we say about count
distinct so if you is a
constant the number of registers in what
is a
constant how how do you when when you
use
cation for the model you just use a
number so I mean if if you're looking at
your memory your memory can be of of
polom size it need to contain your input
and then other things and then each
memory cell is of
logarithm so you can store yeah elements
that you need a logiic number of bus to
to represent
basically good so then let's take half
an hour break and then come back and
continue our open
discussions thank
you